so i'm a stanford professor and a
co-founder of coursera
today most people will never have access
to a stanford class
but we're changing that
working with universities like stanford
princeton caltech pen and others we're
taking classes from these top
universities and putting them on the web
free for anyone to take most of our
classes have enrollments of tens of
thousands or more of students and i
think we launched the mooc or the
massive open online courses movement out
of stanford
before diving into details let me show
you some of the classes we have
welcome to calculus
50 million people are uninsured models
help us organize information they help
us make better predictions they help us
design more effective institutions and
policies models and shorts just make it
better and if we run this we get
unbelievable segregated so bush imagined
that in the future you'd wear a camera
right in the center of your head
a love poem was a poem about another
person nils wants the student of
sociology to develop the hanging cable
takes on the form of a hyperbolic cosine
for each pixel in the image
set the red to zero so let's see what
that looks like and that vaccine allowed
us to eliminate polio virus does
lufthansa serve breakfast and san jose
well that sounds funny so this is which
coin you pick
and this is the key possible zero from
being passive so passive becomes a best
response
so using technology we're addressing the
problem of high quality education at
scale
let me share with you my experience
as a stanford professor i normally teach
here a 400 student class
last year i put my class online and i
reached an audience of a hundred
thousand students
to put that number in context in order
to reach a comparable size audience i
would otherwise have had to teach my
normal stanford class for um
250 years
so
who were the students it was students
like akash middle class family in india
would never have access to stanford
calls otherwise
or students like jenny 39 year old
single mother of two who would otherwise
not have access to these classes
what made his most successful i think
first and i guess
to report to your current progress since
this project launched about a year ago
16 universities have announced
partnerships with us
um
since announcing our first set of
partnerships in april we reached a
million students about a month ago
reached a million students faster than
facebook and in the months since then
we've grown another 25 percent
so why are so many students taking our
classes first and foremost i think
there's a notion that they are real
causes so the class begins on a certain
date it runs for a certain fixed period
of time 10 weeks in the case of my class
and
this is a plot of the amount of web
traffic in my class as it ran those
peaks those heart beats correspond to
when there was a homework due
so predictably the 24 hours before a
deadline is spikes which proves that
procrastination is a global phenomenon
and when a student completes the class
they get a certificate or similar from
us
um this is what the classes look like
like many others we use video-based
instruction
this shows students watching the videos
that celebrate the playback
english captioning which is useful for
non-native speakers of english
as well as foreign language captioning
with our crowd source translations
and rather than having hour-long videos
we instead take complex concepts and ask
instructors to break them down into
short video chunks thus allowing
instructors to post optional
prerequisite or optional advanced
material and allowing the students to
navigate through the content in their
own at their own pace in their own
ordering move us as moving us away from
the one-size-fits-all model of education
but a class is more than just lectures
and we know that students learn best not
by passively listening but by having
opportunities to practice with the
material this is one of my favorite
studies that appeared in science last
year that shows that if a student
studies the material they achieve a
certain level of performance if they
study repeatedly repeat they do a bit
better but it's really the process of
being tested on the material retrieval
practice is being tested on the material
that causes the neural pathways to be
formed that corresponds to long-term
retention
so we built entire clauses and for
opportunities for students to practice
with the material let me show you an
example with what we call in-video
quizzes which are questions that you get
asked right in the middle of a lecture
prospect theory hyperbolic discounting
status quo bias base rate bias they're
all well documented so they're all
well-documented deviations so when the
lecture reaches where the yellow notches
the video pauses and every student has
asked the question you get to summon an
answer your student's not quite right
they correct it
resubmit it
and uh get to see an optional
explanation
and then class moves on
to contrast this with my experience
teaching my stanford class when i ask a
question in class usually half of my
class is still madly scribbling away
trying to write down the last thing i
said um maybe about ten percent of zelda
on facebook and there's
and there's always that one smiley pants
sitting in the first row that blurts out
the answer and then i feel really good
that someone answered my question and
the class moves on so only one student
got to attempt an answer
ironically a website can be more
interactive where every student gets to
attempt an answer every student gets
instant feedback on whether they're
getting it
of course not all homeworks can be is
just multiple choice uh can be auto
graded and so in order to enable the
more open-ended critical thinking types
of exercises put a lot of work into
developing a peer grading system in
which students can say write a 300 word
essay every student is trained to grade
other students work and every student is
then responsible for grading say five
other students work and in exchange to
get feedback from five other students
about their work this has been key to
allow us to offer classes in poetry
humanities social sciences and so on
um peer grading has been well studied
pedagogically to give accurate grades
and would run now by far the largest
peer-graded classes
with tens of thousands of students
when you have 100 000 students the
community naturally forms around the
content it turns out that
no matter what time of day you're awake
thinking about the material there will
be someone and sometimes they'll awake
thinking about the same thing as you are
they can discuss it with you
last year when a student posted a
question on the discussion forum the
median response time to a question was
22 minutes which is a far better level
of service than i ever offered to my
students
and in addition to the online community
physical study groups have been
organically popping up as well this
picture that we took fairly recently and
students are forming physical
communities as well
to wrap up
i've often pronounced the past few
months if you can go online and take a
princeton class for free why would
anyone still pay 200 000 for a princeton
degree
so mark twain
didn't think college was worth the price
of admission
but i disagree going even further back
here's a different quote by pluto which
is that the mine is not a vessel that
needs filling the wood that needs
igniting i think the real value of
attending a top university like
princeton or catholic at stanford is not
just the content content is increasingly
free on the web anyway instead i think
is the interactions the professors
interactions of other equally bright
students so many of the universities
working with us by putting the lectures
online and asking students to watch the
videos online are now able to create
even more time more space in the
classroom for these interactions which i
think is a real value of attending a top
university
finally in the last year half year i
spent a lot of time talking to people
about education
i find that even today a lot of people
say that high quality education is only
for the elite
a lot of people say the high quality
education is only for the privilege
i say the high quality education is a
fundamental human right and with
technology we're working to bring that
to everyone thank you
about do they get a degree or do they
get credit at some point can everybody
hear the question
um right so for now they're getting
certificates from us a piece of paper
like a statement of commercial circular
completion many of our students are
proudly listing their certificates on
their resumes and successfully using
them to get better jobs our partner
universities are not offering academic
credit but one interesting development
has been that many universities around
the world are offering credit for our
classes so we had nothing to do with
this
the university of helsinki for example
asked their students to come and take
closer classes and said you know come
back and show the course services to us
and we'll give you a
academic credit that is good towards the
degree at university of helsinki
so we have nothing to do with this but
this is slowly growing i think it's a
great development for the students
you know i see more and more
universities moving in this direction
the university of washington has also
announced that they will be offering
full credit classes using this sort of
platform with some add-on things um i
think we've all seen the numbers about
the the challenges of cost lack of
access and mixed quality of higher
education if and we're selling our
graduates with these massive debts and
then only half of them are even in jobs
that require college degree um i think
we need to do something to bend the cost
curve for higher education and this
might be a step in that direction
change the world